well nv energy is doing its part to  assist seniors the energy company is  holding expos to manage costs and lower  energy bills seniors 62 and over are  invited to apply for up to 300  in electric and gas assistance now it's  happening on thursday from 8 in the  morning to noon at the alliante casino  and hotel grand ballroom you can meet in  person with customer service  representatives to help you apply  southwest gas representatives will also  be on site to help seniors apply for  energy share gas bill assistance  to qualify for nb energy's assistance  program we ask that you're age 62 or  more  you bring your id and proof of income  and we can get you served  well so far nv energy says they've  helped nearly 600 seniors with their  energy bills and we have more  information on our website eight newsnow  dot com